[Musique]
il se passe des choses étranges à France
Miniature le Gendarme de Saint-Tropez
les trois mousquetaires ou encore les
rois de France se sont invités sur le
parc pour Halloween ils ont amené avec
eux de l'eau de la quelques copains et
des décors aussi amusants que terrifiant
on voit des squelettes des
chauves-souris des toiles d'araignées
jusqu'au 6 novembre c'est dans ce décor
que les visiteurs pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir la France et ses monuments
en miniatures c'est une belle initiative
d'avoir un tel
patrimoine français on nous donne la
visiter en une journée avec la
possibilité de faire cette découverte et
donc c'est plutôt une très belle balade
familiale et une belle un bon moment de
l'histoire à la visite s'ajoute des
activités spéciales Halloween les
familles pourront se tester autour d'un
jeu de piste et d'énigmes dans le but de
retrouver les bijoux dérobés de la reine
aliénos de la citrouille on se plaît à
découvrir les questions et à se
réinterroger notre culture générale au
programme également des jeux
l'incontournable distribution de bonbons
et des animations
à France Miniature Halloween fait partie
des temps forts de la vie du parc du pie
maintenant quelques années on peut pas
faire des vacances de la Toussaint sans
une animation Halloween et du coup
chaque année on agrémente avec des
nouveaux décors on va trouver cette
année des personnages un peu typiques
dans les régions de France avec des
costumes assez sordides pour certains
mais on reste vraiment sur du rigolo
effrayant alors
osez vous vous aventurer au parc pour
Halloween